How about Sam Smith and never it again?
Yeah.
A viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people falling in love.
We want it to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Amy and I am super single.
My last relationship was a year and a half ago.
I've been very ready to go back into the dating game.
My name is Joey Jennings and I'm currently single.
I have kind of messed around with the online dating apps.
You kind of get to know them like through the bio and there's,
but you can't really trust that,
you know,
so technically no,
I've never been on a full on blind date like this.
I have no idea what I'm in for,
but accepted with a big hug.
Hi
Amy.
Nice to meet you too.
I'm Joey.
Hi Joey.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you as well.
Said that twice.
I feel a little on edge,
but like in a good way.
It's not a nervous thing.
It's just like anticipation and like a little bit.
Do you like tea?
Yes.
Cheers.
For Tea.
I want to do that.
She was tea.
Woo.
I have no idea what flavor it is,
but it's tea.
So it's good for the soul.
Um,
when did you last seen to yourself and to someone else?
Oh Man,
last time I sang to myself was yesterday and the shower,
I love singing,
like writing my own music,
a good singer.
I'm tone deaf.
I can't carry a tune.
I'll sing something and I'll be like,
that's so not what it sounded like in my head.
How about Sam Smith and it again and again.
To me,
just your energy and your smile while you're singing it is just,
that's more of a treat to me.
Take one minute and tell your partner your life story as much detail as
possible.
Born and raised in southern California.
Middle School was pretty rough for me.
I was,
how's it really awkward kid.
Sophomore year I,
um,
started going through some really bad depression and um,
that's something I still deal with today.
I don't know exactly where it comes from.
There's so many different sources.
I dropped out of high school sophomore year cause it was that bad and I don't
know if you know next models.
Uh,
so this one woman saw me.
It was just like,
you work for anyone.
I'm just like,
what do you mean?
He's just like,
do you model and how did that play into your depression?
It definitely fed my ego a bunch and I was just like,
okay as a shit,
everyone at school was like,
oh he's living the dream.
Dropped out of high school and becoming a model.
And I got my Instagram going and everyone was like,
oh look at this.
Like no,
I have clinical depression and being chopped out because of the,
can you keep up with the system?
As you can tell,
I'm pretty open about sharing that because I know so many other people have it
and it's not something to be ashamed of at all.
It shouldn't be 19 to where I am now.
I started a surfing business,
so if I can make enough money to support myself,
do things,
I love that success.
I would've never asked the guests that you have like clinical depression and
it's something that you've struggled with now.
Yeah.
Not many people think that at all.
They just say snap out of it.
You got to everything you want.
I think when my mom would say to me,
I was born in the bay,
but I moved here when I was three.
My mom was the breadwinner and my dad was the homemakers who was the one
braiding my hair,
taking me to school beyond my recitals.
And I actually didn't start seeing my mom or like cultivating relationships with
there until I was like 15 things that you would relate masculinity in this
society.
Like I learned it off of my mom,
like how to negotiate a business deal,
how to present yourself.
And then my dad was the one who was like,
if I said I was like fat,
he'd be like,
hey man,
you're so like,
you're fine.
You don't need a workout.
And my mom would be like,
go work out.
You're pathetic.
You're a loser with her.
She's really unhappy.
So I think seeing that growing up,
I was like,
there's something missing.
If I have to trade all my time to make money,
where do I have the time to enjoy that money?
Exactly.
As soon as I graduated from Ucla,
my mom was like,
you know you're making like x amount of money.
Like go follow your dream.
I support you because I heard it from her.
I was like,
yeah,
of course.
Because like everything I did was to impress her.
What would constitute a perfect day for you?
I'm like,
perfect day would be sleeping in,
eating something very healthy,
but a delicious,
so like in a cycle and then probably spending it in like nature can be simple.
What about you?
I would wake up at five 30 in the morning and goes down surfing after five 30 to
seven 30 I'd go snowboarding and after that if I could at night I'd go
skydiving.
What are you be trained by the end of the day though?
I feel like you're like extreme,
extreme,
extreme.
I'm getting energy from it.
Bounces it,
man.
What is your most terrible memory?
It's extreme.
I basically got expelled for making them my space of a teacher by six was just a
new thing.
And you know,
people were scared of like crisis,
like killers and stuff like that.
And the Internet was a very scary thing.
It was still dial up.
They like purposely like kind of teasing or no,
I actually made her a gap model and then,
and I'm literally like,
like straight a student.
Like I'm on the honor roll.
And then I got excelled and from a small town,
so literally everyone knew about it and I spent every single day crying and then
my dad came into the room and he just started sobbing with me on the bed.
I was the sounds like a sweetheart.
Oh yeah he is.
But like just that moment,
I never want to feel that way every year of my life.
For me it's gotta be a scooter accident.
I was seven years old.
You know how it has those puffy handles?
Everything.
Okay.
Well one of them was off.
One of the screws of the front front wheels fell off.
I just nosedive face planted and at the same time the scooter handle drove up my
chin and through my mouth it bypass the bones and just went.
It was awful,
but I was in so much shock that I didn't even realize it.
I didn't feel the pain.
I was just like,
I was just dizzy and like wondering what just happened.
There was blood all over the driveway.
I was bleeding out.
Just my whole face was being drained.
Was crazy.
Like out of all of that,
that's the score that you got?
Yeah,
I think it's quite small.
It's shrunk but it was like that big,
oh my,
you know,
so that was more physically painful,
emotionally painful,
alternate sharing something you consider a positive characteristic of your
partner right off the bat you have a beautiful smile and you're very positive
and you're very outgoing.
I think you're a very positive person and I think I said earlier like I would've
never guessed that someone like you was like dealing with clinical depression
and I think that shows a lot about how strong you are too.
I think it also fearless.
That's what I've noticed.
When I see you,
I'm like,
this guy is fearless.
Like your like your perfect day.
It has to do with snowboarding,
like surfing or you just seem very overall positive and you're like a very
resilient person.
I can tell.
Thank you.
Yeah,
that means a lot.
Where'd you go on a second date with your partner?
Yes,
I would say yeah.
Interesting person.
Yeah,
for sure.
I feel like you had a lot to talk about.
I can definitely see us hanging out.
So talking more about our personal lives.
Yes,
I will.
For free to no,
I live.
Wow.
As soon as he said,
I was like,
I'll pay you two cause I respect your services.
Let's go on our date.
Nice.
Hi everyone.
I'm toy from jubilee.
Thank you so much for watching this video.
If you would like to be in one of these videos,
make sure you check out our casting form.
The link is down below and maybe we will match up you for the next one.
Um,
as always,
please subscribe,
watch more videos and we will see you in the next one.
Why.